et on va plus loin avec Madame mostaf
Avid directrice adjointe de la rédaction
de L'Express bonjour à Madame
l'hebdomadaire inquiétude sur les
États-Unis grand gagnant de la guerre
évidemment de la guerre en Ukraine on
l'a compris face à vous Bruno Daru de la
rédaction de France Inter dont joue
Bruno bonjour Raphaël ils n'en peuvent
plus des restrictions liées à la
politique zéro covid et il le dit des
milliers de Chinois manifestent comme
jamais sans doute sur le continent
depuis 1989 elle tient elle-même ça
rappelle des souvenirs aux autorités
écoutez ce que dit ces manifestants il
brandissent pour beaucoup une simple
feuille blanche en guise de pancarte de
revendication
on ne peut jamais rien dire alors on
utilise ce morceau de papier blanc tout
ce qu'on pourra dire sera censuré
on se mobilise contre la dictature du
test PCR et vous savez contre si j'ai
pimping
on se mobilise contre la dictature du
test PCR Jinping n'était pas au début un
mouvement de rébellion contre le pouvoir
Bruno juste un mouvement d'exaspération
mais ça pourrait bien devenir oui ça
pourrait bien le devenir parce que ça a
très vite basculé ce week-end même s'il
l'exaspération liée au confinement au
test à répétition
date du printemps dernier puisque il y a
déjà eu des vidéos qui ont circulé des
étudiants qui se sont mobilisés donc là
c'est un peu le point d'orgue suite à
l'incendie meurtrier qui s'est déroulée
à euromshi dans le shinge ou les
restrictions liées au confinement en
fait on s'en doute empêché les pompiers
d'arriver à temps pour pour sauver des
vies donc là c'est un peu ça c'est un
peu explosé dans la rue si vous voulez
des centaines voire des milliers on ne
sait pas exactement parce que les
chiffres en Chine c'est toujours c'est
toujours compliqué et effectivement tout
de suite dès ce week-end certes des
slogans contre les restrictions liées au
confinement et donc contre la liberté de
se déplacer de circuler d'aller chercher
de quoi de quoi se nourrir mais très
vite dans un régime comme ça on bascule
sur la critique politique avec des
slogans quand même que on n'avait pas vu
depuis fort longtemps depuis 33 ans des
slogans mais même qu'on voyait pas en 89
chez jimping démission à balle Parti
communiste donc ça ce sont des slogans
très politiques qui font que le pouvoir
a essayé aujourd'hui de réagir allez
derrière cette colère il y a une remise
en cause tout simplement du bien fondé
des mesures imposées par les autorités
au regard de leur pertinence
scientifique écoutez
on veut des mesures anticoïdes basées
sur la science
[Applaudissements]
je pense que les choses devraient
revenir à la normale on doit retrouver
nos vies d'avant
sur la prétendue discipline du peuple
chinois et ça craint du covid on avait
sous-estimé la capacité des Chinois à
exprimer finalement leur esprit critique
et leur colère c'est vrai que c'est
inattendu surtout que ça intervient un
mois après un concert de congrès du PCC
qui était assez triomphaliste pour chez
INPI qui s'est fait relié pour un
troisième mandat historique donc c'est
vrai que on était vraiment là dedans
donc voilà les chinois ils acceptent le
pouvoir de c'est une pin et je pense que
ça reste vrai parce que c'est pas non
plus Tinan men là mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que il y a eu il a commis quand
même pas mal d'erreurs notamment
dans le fait de la stratégie anticoïdes
qui était bien au début du covid quand
on n'avait pas de vaccin et quand le
monde entier était confiné bon ça peut
leur poser pas de problème aujourd'hui
il y a la Coupe du Monde de du Qatar les
chinois sont fans de foot ils voient ces
stades plein de gens ils se disent bah
pourquoi tous les autres peuvent le
faire et pas nous après évidemment il y
a pas que ça il y a pas que le je pense
qu'il y a pas que l'histoire du covid il
y a quand même aussi le fait
qu'aujourd'hui la Chine n'est pas dans
la croissance économique qu'elle a connu
il y a le chômage des jeunes on a fait à
L'Express une une il y a trois semaines
qui s'appelait le grand bon en arrière
le grand bon en arrière c'est cette idée
que la Chine elle est plus dans cette
dynamique dans laquelle elle a été
pendant longtemps et même si ils ont une
vue à très loin eux ils visent d'être
premier puissance du monde en 2049 donc
on n'est pas exactement sur les mêmes
échelles de temps que nous c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand même un
creux qui fait que il y a une sorte de
cocktail explosif qui fait que même les
Chinois entre guillemets les plus
dociles en ont ras-le-bol et exprime
leur leur insatisfaction oui lorsque la
croissance ralentie lorsqu'on voit ces
images Bruno a effectivement de deux
Coupes du monde qu'on voit tous et
convivi eux aussi les Chinois même si on
essaie de leur masquer l'absence de
masque justement
lorsqu'il voit que ce n'est pas
seulement l'Europe ou l'Occident
décadents mais mais le Moyen-Orient qui
aussi se découvre à l'occasion d'un
match de foot le dogme d'infaillibilité
de leur dirigeants et est tombé d'une
certaine mère c'est une barrière mentale
qui s'effondre c'est peut-être un peu
tôt pour le dire mais en tout cas encore
une fois le le fait que chez jimping
soit désigné nommément comme étant celui
qui doit quitter le pouvoir de le fait
qu'il y ait des critiques du Parti
communiste ça c'est quand même quand
même très très nouveau alors
effectivement on en est pas encore à
Tian'anmen l'avenir nous dira si si ça
va jusque là mais oui en fait c'est un
peu chez inping lui-même qui s'est mis
dans cette position parce que il a fait
de cette politique de zéro covid
tellement sa politique qu'en fait
maintenant il se retrouve un peu coincé
alors il se retrouve coincé d'une
certaine manière parce qu'effectivement
la politique de zéro covid et l'échec
quand même assez massif du vaccin
chinois a fait que il a été obligé de
poursuivre cette politique de zéro covid
parce que la crainte quand même c'est
que comme il y a très peu de chinois
vaccinés notamment dans les classes les
plus âgées et notamment donc les plus de
80 ans et que le vaccin n'est pas très
opérant et que beaucoup de Chinois
refusent de se faire vacciner
effectivement s'ils ouvrent trop en fait
ils ont peur que la pandémie
littéralement explose c'est le
nationalisme vaccinal il y a une sorte
de nationalisme vaccinal parce
qu'évidemment le chez jimping et le
parti refuse de reconnaître que sur ce
plan-là les vaccins des Occidentaux avec
la RN messager que les Chinois n'ont pas
mis en œuvre bah étaient supérieure au
vaccin chinois mais ça il peut pas le
reconnaître donc il se met dans
l'interdiction de d'importer des vaccins
ARN sans compter que il en faudrait
évidemment vu la population il en
faudrait énormément donc ils sont un peu
coincés d'un point à la fois d'un point
de vue sanitaire et aussi d'un point de
vue du coup politique idéologique et
nationaliste mais justement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout est devenu
idéologies qu'on nationaliste et les
Chinois même si finalement c'est un
régime idéologique qui a toujours eu une
de pragmatisme aussi une forme
d'ouverture économique parce que voilà
pour être dans le libre-échange et dans
les gains économiques aujourd'hui même
l'économie il a remplacé quelqu'un qui
était assez ouvert par qui avait été
étudié à l'étranger par quelqu'un qui
est lui beaucoup plus dans un homme du
sérail qui connaît moins l'économie pour
la santé on est aussi on refuse les
vaccins
occidentaux qui sont plus efficaces
parce que on veut nos propres vaccins en
fait tout est idéologique nationaliste
et du coup ça donne des décisions
abérantes qui au bout d'un moment énerve
et puis peut-être aussi c'est ce qui est
important quand même en fait il y avait
un espèce de deal entre le régime et la
et la population chinoise surtout après
Étienne admet c'était bon en gros enfin
pour faire très simple On vous retire
vos libertés mais on vous prospérité et
la prospérité et là c'est cette
équilibre là c'est ce ce cet accord qui
qui est en train un peu de de se
déchirer ce qui fait que les gens disent
déjà on n'avait pas beaucoup de liberté
là on en a encore moins et en plus cette
politique de zéro covid
débouche sur une situation économique
qui n'est pas bonne du tout y compris
pour nous au quotidien et c'est là aussi
que ça se joue et que c'est très
dangereux potentiellement pour le parti
lui-même et on sent aussi alors c'est un
peu comme le PC soviétique à la belle
époque difficile de savoir ce qui s'y
joue exactement mais en fait on se
souvient pendant le congrès de l'image
quand même de l'ancien président
rougitao étant sorti quasiment de de la
salle ce qui veut dire quand même que le
clan et en fait visiblement il
protestait parce que son clan n'était
pas représenté parmi les 7 il y a cette
petite empereurs en haut qui entoure
chez gimping et que à l'intérieur du PC
faut pas croire que c'est si
monolithique que ça et on va voir
comment ça évolue si s'il y a une
évolution politique il y aura ça sera
peut-être pas une des réglement de
compte à l'intérieur du parti communiste
oui il a encore plus centralisé c'est
vrai que c'est important de se rappeler
que dans le PCC il y a quand même bien
références tendances différentes
tendances qui sont certaines aussi plus
pour l'ouverture et plus pour un certain
pragmatise au moins économiques et que
lui il a vraiment concentré autour de
lui que des gens qui vont dire oui à
toutes ces politiques du coup c'est sûr
que ça étouffe un peu la question aussi
la question générationnelle des jeunes
aussi qui qui est un peu comme partout
ailleurs ne sont pas forcément d'accord
avec les politiques en place et puis
donc face à ces manifestations et
pouvoir chinois réagir en réprimant ces
manifestations le l'alliance de média de
service public condamne les agressions
contre des journalistes il y a une forme
de fébrilité aujourd'hui du pouvoir
chinois qui est sous le feu des
projecteurs qui est condamné verbalement
par Washington bon c'est pas très
surprenant mais les États-Unis
s'agissent un peu la malleau bon par
l'Allemagne qui alors là les les propos
de Franck waltersteinmeyer le président
sont quand même assez fort parce qu'il
dit comprendre les manifestants chinois
donc il y a une forme d'incitation
presque à manifester et puis même l'ONU
qui sort de sa réserve en appelant à
manifester pacifiquement et donc à
respecter ces manifestations Bruno
est-ce que c'est une c'est utile ou
est-ce que c'est contre-productible
c'est juste de solidarité en risque
justement d'attisé la fébrilité et donc
la réaction du pouvoir chinois
honnêtement je saurais pas vous dire si
la déclara déjà il faut quand même se
rappeler que ces déclarations ne
parviendront sans doute pas très
rapidement aux oreilles des des
manifestants chinois normalement je
crois que le principal danger enfin je
veux dire là on est un peu un jeu de
posture chacun est dans son rôle on dit
bon liberté de manifester etc dans la
guerre là on est plutôt dans la guerre
qui avait des clones entre les
démocraties et les autoritarisme et
c'est un peu ça le temps pour les
autoritarisme en ce moment que ce soit
voilà en Russie en Iran en Chine
finalement on voit des des populations
notamment les les plus jeunes
générations qui se rebellent un peu à
cause aussi de l'importance des réseaux
sociaux qui fait que c'est fini on peut
plus comme avant tout bloquer ne plus
faire circuler l'information donc ça
c'est que les démocraties en profite un
peu et prennent vite revanche bon c'est
un peu normal je sais pas si dans
l'immédiat sera un effet en interne en
attente qui va compter c'est comment au
sein du PC 6 ça se poursuit on va
décider de faire face à ça c'est à dire
soit de faire comme un peu aujourd'hui
quand même une répression pour le moment
selon les les critères chinois on va
dire assez soft c'est à dire que on
bloque les endroits où il y avait les
manifestations on empêche de manifester
visiblement on arrive quand même à
appeler certains manifestants au
téléphone qu'on a quand même repéré donc
on leur met la pression mais il y a pas
encore comme ça se passe en Iran les
arrestations quand même il y a eu des
arrestations mais il y a pas de
répression massive sur les
manifestations de manifestants je pense
mais ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que on sait pas exactement
[Musique]
qu'ils disent mais bon City là où il
construisent tous les iPhones il y a eu
pas mal de monde mais c'est parce qu'il
y a beaucoup d'ouvriers qui sont réunis
au moins va chez Foxton ce qui est un
des rares endroits où il y a les gens
peuvent se parler en vrai aussi c'est ça
qui joue c'est parce que la grande
démission parce qu'on parle de 20000
employés qui seraient partis
à nos côtés pour que vos gouvernements
cessent de soutenir ce régime meurtrier
tueur d'enfants
religieux et ne connaît pas d'autres
lois que celle de la force pour se
maintenir au pouvoir coûte que coûte
les réseaux sociaux à Madame elle a été
arrêtée elle-même avec d'autres
manifestants oui elle a été arrêtée
parce que c'est vraiment une image très
forte
on voit depuis deux mois les
manifestants qui manifestent au cri de
femmes vie liberté
on voit le mouvement de dévoilement
massif alors là ce qui frappe c'est que
c'est une femme voilée qui finalement
vient dénoncer le régime mais pourquoi
parce que en fait
il y a un moment donné voilà les gens
les plus proches aussi quelque part du
régime en tout cas qui sont un peu
religieux vont aussi basculer montrer
leur mécontentement et ça peut être une
sorte de point de bascule dans les
manifestations qui ont lieu depuis deux
mois un nouveau témoignage Bruno de
l'isolement du pouvoir iranien en tout
cas face à une partie de sa jeunesse
puisque là on a affaire à une jeune
femme qui bien qui suit de la famille
alors voilà plus ou moins proche du
Guide suprême et visiblement religieuse
a décidé d'exprimer son refus bah oui
oui moi je rejoins tout à fait ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est à dire que en
fait je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
Iraniens qui trouvent que c'est plus
vraiment même théocratie c'est un espèce
de complexe militaro religieux avec
notamment les Gardiens de la révolution
que ce sont plutôt les les les les
sections militaires on va dire qui qui
ont un peu pris le dessus dans dans
l'exercice voir la confiscation du
pouvoir donc c'est intéressant aussi de
voir qu'il y a ce débat en interne
à l'intérieur de de ce régime
après oui que le régime iranien soit
soit isolé d'une grande partie de sa
population ça fait plus de deux mois que
ça dure c'est clair mais encore une fois
je reviens un peu ce que je disais tout
à l'heure quand même c'est intéressant
de voir qu'en ce moment tous ces régimes
autoritaires sont sont secoués quand
même par toute une génération qui veut
simplement la liberté alors ça bon plus
ou moins
axé sur sur là en Iran notamment c'est
c'est la liberté des femmes en Chine
c'est la liberté la liberté d'expression
on le sent aussi un peu en Russie même
si évidemment c'est très compliqué dans
des systèmes Héroïdes et on voit que ces
systèmes en fait ils sont tellement
autoritaires vont avoir totalitaire en
fait que ils ont toujours peur de de
commencer à lâcher quelque chose parce
que après ils ont peur de l'effondrement
par exemple les les Chinois pour revenir
à l'instant chinois ils ont été
traumatisés par l'épisode Gorbatchev en
Russie voilà et d'ailleurs c'est la
visite d'une visite de Gorbatchev en
Chine qui avait précédé tout ce qui
s'est passé à Tiananmen à l'époque donc
tous ces pouvoirs là aujourd'hui sont
confrontés à ce dilemme un peu
existentiel quand même pour eux merci
Bruno merci à Madame c'était ton va plus
loin rester avec nous prochain journal
dans 3 minutes sur France 24